Clint's whole thing was minimalism and
exactitude which you know I appreciate
Spike Lee does the same thing so it
didn't have a lot of notes
no the only notes he ever gave me uh
were
uh speed like pacing on Richard Jewel a
couple times and and Clint would walk up
to me and go ah it needs a little more
uh
Skip to My Lou Skip to My Lou Pace it up
and I'd be like oh man the boss is right
and by the way I would say eight or nine
out of ten times he was right and I was
milking something uh it mostly
unconsciously and then once in a while
I'd be like uh this like
this is a big this is a big moment I
think the editor should find the pacing
I need to honor this moment and really
feel the breadth of it and make sure
that there's an origin to the conclusion